vous devez trouver à lapins dorés venez
l'amener là non mais à mon top non mais
eksi dahalo avoir fait une tête de cul
non mais ne riez pas une course
faut juste cherché à la vendre mais qui
croule lapins dorés prend le salaire de
l'autre attention c'est parti
top asie go déjà non elle n'a pas
d'oreilles qui est qu on n a pas donné
[Musique]
mais il ya des trucs partout il ya un
truc pas net
jean richert s'est gagné nos jeunes
bravo il offre 10 jeux toilette repas
que vous allez vous mettre en place à
les libérer si khobza bon bah vous
essuyez pas un instant à les îles
baléares ici à nîmes battu peut y aller
aux jo n'est pas l'invention deuxième
équipe
jean-luc contre eux non c'est kelly
contre bernard kelly contre berne a
touché bernard kerik autres bernard jean
thomas bernard salvetois à distance de
sécurité à bon attention
trois deux un top 3 à la penderie à la
pandora tension d'antalgiques cela
n'apparaisse que talla parc qui doit
oui je sais que ma joie rien bon alors
vais vite il est où le n'a pas été
tellement bien tâche et leur syndicat et
occupez-vous de remarques mais il est là
des chocolats merci merci merci kelly
merci c'est bon personne n'a trouvé
personne ne prend le salaire de l'autre
de toutes les façons quand ce bike et
dit c'est pas une artiste s ouais
attention il a été préservé
benjamin contre vanessa lemoine qui
vient nous voir de benchmark yvette
autour de la table ce soir allez c'est
parti
c'est beau mais c'est quoi ce délire
tout fait qu elle limitera lizzy a été
retrouvé à la point d'eau le premier qui
trouve le lapin doré repart avec un
salaire de l'autre à ça ça m'intéresse
ah bah oui surtout castaldi ou et lui en
marche mais ça chauffe là bas ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors à vous de juillet là tout va très
bien et attention attention on à
jean-luc contre maxime jean luc maxime
et jean-luc jean-luc maxime attention il
faut prendre le lapin d'oreilles celui
qui trouve le lapin doré ancien havrais
dit maxime va vers la droite jean-luc
vers la gauche celui qui trouve le lapin
doré gagne le salaire de l'autre allez-y
non non non non l'avant et y est froid
c'est vrai quoi froisser fera toutefois
non non non non c'est froid
non jean-luc reste plutôt à gauche mais
ces malades
[Musique]
allez-y vite vite vite vite moati
seconde non non c'est froid là c'est
fois raison
c'est plein de chocolat
mais non les mecs mégalo et c'est le
seul gars qui sauva des plats dits bon
c'est bon allez c'est terminé
personne de gamme de salades aux
nouvelles on peut être animal actions
pour lever les assiettes pour les
derniers essais et si on peut enlever
les assets parce que là on va être
grillé donc attention et parce que là il
reste geely label j aurais pas le gâcher
on a vu toute la journée à faire cette
lourdeur franchement si nous lagache
attention si vous vous devriez mettre
une petite serviette là vous rien est
une petite série médium est posée juste
une serviette m'étais juste une
serviette
c'est pas la peine 1 11 ça va ça ça se
virent à c'est juste une serviette jours
voilà de plage
laurent tapie bras la bravoure et la
générosité malin dernier couple dernier
couple dernier couple isabelle contre
gilles c'est parti
mais j'adore ce qu'ils veulent même pas
le plateau lieu ou alors les chiffres
attendez vous allez avoir une minute
pour trouver le lapin daury d'accord il
trouvera le lapin doré et gagnera le
salaire de l'autre
maintenant on y va pas voir la nuit
c'est direct 1
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
merci le shérif prochain c'était au
brésil